monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
rappelez vous de la discussion de
colbert et mazarin colbert pour trouver
de l'argent il arrive un moment où
tripoter ne suffit plus
j'aimerais que monsieur le surintendant
m'explique comment on s'y prend pour
dépenser encore quand on est endetté
jusqu'au cou
mazarin quand on est un simple mortel
bien sûr et qu'on est couvert de dettes
on va en prison
l'état colbert et comment on trouvait
quand on a déjà créé tous les impôts
imaginables mazarin de lui répondre
on en crée d'autres colbert nous ne
pouvons pas taxer les pauvres puissent
qu'ils ne le sont déjà
mazarin les riches non plus il ne
dépenseraient plus mazarin toujours eni
à quantité de gens qui sont entre les
deux ni pauvres ni riches des français
qui travaillent rêvant d'être riche et
redoutant d'être pauvre c'est cela que
nous devons taxer encore plus toujours
plus
cela plus tu leur prends plus il
travaille pour compenser c'est un
réservoir inépuisable
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
et bien monsieur le premier ministre
ne pensez vous pas qu aujourd'hui le
réservoir est épuisé
la parole
et un françois de rugy ministre d'état
me disent de la transition écologique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur du plomb nous sommes plus tout
à fait à l'époque de colbert de mazarin
la différence est peut-être qui est du
reste et je n'en sais rien pour notre
part nous avons mis les choses sur la
table et nous avons dit aux français la
vérité lorsque nous avons été élus
l'avons dit avant ne la vie a mis en
oeuvre après et nous avons dit il faut
moins taxer le travail moins taxés
l'emploi - taxer les entreprises et
davantage taxer la pollution et le
carbone et nous l'avons fait et nous
avons pris des mesures d'accompagnement
parce qu'il faut accompagner les
français dans ce changement
je pense qu'à l'époque des évidemment de
mazarin et de colbert on ne se
préoccupait pas beaucoup du dérèglement
climatique et donc nous avons pris des
mesures pour changer de voiture
je ne sais pas monsieur du plomb
monsieur le sénateur du plomb
je ne sais pas si ça vous intéresse mais
250 mille français ont pu changer de
voiture grâce à une prime à l'achat de
1000 ou 2000 euros moi j'en suis très
heureux un million de français ont pu
faire des travaux d'économie d'énergie
cette année grâce au crédit d'impôt
je pense que c'est une excellente chose
3 millions six cent mille français ont
également bénéficié du chèque énergie et
je crois également que c'est nécessaire
pour passer pour passer ce moment
difficile
et puisque vous aimez les citations je
vais à mon tour vous en donner lecture
d'une hier j'étais au lycée clemenceau à
nantes et j'ai donc donné la définition
du courage pour georges clemenceau le
courage c'est d'aller tout droit devant
soi on doit en souffrir
on sera à détester méprisés on recevra
de la boue on n'aura pas
d'applaudissements mais il faut savoir
choisir entre les applaudissements
d'aujourd'hui qui sont d'un certain prix
est ce qu'on se donne à soi même
quand avant d'entrer dans le néant on
peut se dire j'ai donné à mon pays ce
que je pouvais monsieur du plomb
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre
eh bien monsieur le premier ministre
n'entendez vous pas le ras-le-bol des
français ils payent plus pour le
carburant plus pour le gaz plus pour la
cg alors que dans le même temps votre
gouvernement est incapable de contenir
le déficit public annoncés à près de 100
milliards d'euros en 2019 et de
maîtriser la dette qui sera bientôt à
100% du pib et votre gouvernement donne
en plus des leçons à tout le monde aux
élus pour leur gestion aux
automobilistes pour leur conduite à ceux
qui fument des clopes et rouleaux peu au
diesel à ceux qui ne seraient pas assez
écolo gist ou progressistes méfiez vous
monsieur le premier ministre je dis bien
monsieur le premier ministre en restant
sourd de ne pas faire la même erreur que
marie antoinette qui avait dit pendant
la dizaine de 1789
s'ils n'ont pas de pain qu'ils mangent
de la brioche
[Applaudissements]